(shuffling)
- Jordan Klepper here.
It's almost Thanksgiving,
our most peaceful
American holiday,
but in our current
political climate,
Thanksgiving with family
can be a bit tough.
Thanksgiving is by far
the most appropriate time
to change another person's
deeply held core beliefs.
This is the time to pounce,
find the weakness that lies
in familial bonds
and tryptophan,
and finally, win the day.
Here's some tips.
- [Football Player] Hut! Hut!
(whistle blows)
- Put the big game
on every channel.
Make sure everyone
stands for the Anthem,
regardless of age
or joint health.
If you trigger them
early and often
they'll weaken over time.
(gentle piano music)
Take every opportunity,
and inject their small
talk with your big talk.
Hey Cousin Sheila, fuck
your baby's first steps.
Chem trails are real.
(gentle piano music)
You'll know they are weakening
if they say they don't
want to talk politics.
Let's just enjoy the meal.
This, this is your moment.
Throw the entire pumpkin
pie at the wall and shout,
(pie hits, pie hits again)
"Politics are the meal!"
- [Distorted Voice]
Politics are the meal.
(gentle piano music)
- Every family has that uncle
who ruins every holiday.
I am that holiday uncle.
You, and that holiday uncle.
We, and that holiday uncle.
Happy Thanksgiving.
(gentle piano music)
(squelching)
(rock music)